como podríamos describir la rotación en
tres dimensiones por ejemplo aquí tengo
una esfera que está rotando de alguna
forma verdad tiene cierta dirección y
está rotando a cierta velocidad y la
pregunta es cómo podríamos dar cierta
información numérica que perfectamente
describa esta rotación así que por
ejemplo si me dieras algunos números que
de alguna forma podríamos decir la de la
velocidad y la dirección y todo lo que
está asociado con esta rotación antes de
hablar de eso vamos a recordar como
hablábamos de la rotación en dos
dimensiones aquí tengo una criatura y
verdad y para describir cómo está
moviéndose necesitamos una tasa de
rotación verdad que esencialmente es el
número de rotaciones por segundo
digamos podríamos pensar en cualquier
unidad del tiempo este es el número de
rotaciones por segundo verdad así que
las rotaciones por segundo en este caso
digamos yo lo programe para que hiciera
una rotación por cada cinco segundos
esto nos da una tasa rotacional de 0.2
verdad pero esto es un poco ambiguo
porque podríamos decir bueno esta
criatura está rotando a punto dos
rotaciones por segundo y alguien podría
preguntarnos bueno lo hace en el sentido
ahora
antihorario así que hay cierta
ambigüedad y la convención que la gente
ha adoptado es que el signo positivo
verdad nos dice que va en el sentido
antihorario en contra de las manecillas
del reloj pero si damos un número
negativo entonces tendríamos una
rotación verdad en el sentido contrario
es decir en el sentido horario es decir
de las manecillas del reloj y esto es
muy bonito porque simplemente
necesitamos un número verdad que puede
ser positivo o negativo y perfectamente
describe la rotación en dos dimensiones
y hay quizás algún pequeño digamos
matriz verdad porque usualmente en
física y en matemáticas no usamos
rotaciones por unidad
por digamos por segundo sino que
describimos cosas en términos de los
radiales por segundo así que solo para
recordar lo que significa si imaginamos
este círculo y dibujamos el radio nos
preguntamos qué tanto avanzamos en la
circunferencia para que esa longitud de
arco verdad sea exactamente
tan larga como el radio así que digamos
si el radio es r y quisiéramos que esta
longitud de arco también fuera r verdad
entonces el ángulo que formamos digamos
cantidad de vuelta que damos determina
un radiante y debido a que hay dos
radiales en cada rotación para convertir
rotaciones por segundo a radiales por el
segundo simplemente tendríamos que
multiplicar esto por dos verdad
simplemente el número que obtengamos ahí
hay que multiplicar por dos pi y digamos
el número específico en realidad no es
muy importante aquí lo los centrales que
con un simple número positivo o negativo
podemos describir perfectamente las
rotaciones en dos dimensiones ahora sí
regresamos al caso de tres dimensiones
necesitamos más información y una forma
en la que vamos a proceder verdad
necesitamos primero un eje de rotación
alrededor del cual está girando nuestra
esfera verdad así que esta línea que
hemos dibujado nos dice alrededor de que
se ocurre verdad y luego si queremos
describir la tasa la cual está
moviéndose en entonces necesitamos una
dirección y también una magnitud y
entonces uno puede decir su dirección y
magnitud suena que podríamos usar un
vector vamos a usar un vector cuya
longitud esencialmente corresponda a la
tasa a la cual está rotando típicamente
en radiales por segundo ya eso le
llamamos veloz
angular y la dirección describe el eje
de rotación en sí mismo pero digamos de
la misma forma que en dos dimensiones
tenemos una ambigüedad entre la rotación
en sentido horario o antihorario y la
ambigüedad en este caso proviene de
determinar si elegimos el vector blanco
o el verde verdad el verde es
simplemente el blanco pero en sentido
opuesto y es que en realidad no importa
donde los esté colocando recuerden que
los vectores podemos colocarlos donde
sea pero aquí he decidido ponerlos en
los polos para que podamos distinguirlos
muy bien y para esto para está digamos
ambigüedad tenemos una convención que
conocemos como la regla de la mano
derecha
entonces déjenme traer una imagen para
que puedas ver justamente a que se
refiere esta regla y la idea que tenemos
que tener en mente es que digamos las
yemas de nuestros dedos estarán
moviéndose en la dirección en la que la
superficie de nuestra esfera también se
mueve y entonces cuando levantamos
nuestro pulgar esa es la dirección en la
que elegimos el vector que describe a
esta rotación así que en este ejemplo
específico que tenemos cuando levantamos
nuestro pulgar derecho eso corresponde
al vector
blanco no al verde pero si hiciéramos
todo al revés es decir que la rotación
vaya en el sentido contrario verdad en
la dirección opuesta entonces podríamos
imaginar que doblamos nuestros dedos de
la mano derecha alrededor de esa
dirección y entonces el pulgar estaría
apuntando de acuerdo como lo dice el
vector verde pero en la rotación
original que con la que iniciamos verdad
es el vector blanco y el vector blanco
es el con el que vamos a continuar allí
de hecho esto está genial verdad porque
en realidad estamos comprimiendo toda la
información en un solo vector y eso es
lo que nos dice el eje nos dice la
velocidad de rotación a través de su
magnitud y la elección de la dirección
digamos a lo largo del eje nos dice cuál
es el sentido de rotación de nuestra
esfera así que con estos tres números
verdad las las tres coordenadas de este
vector perfectamente describen cualquier
rotación en tres dimensiones y la razón
por la cual estoy hablando de esto es
porque en los vídeos sobre rotación nada
vamos a estar hablando de el rotacional
en tres dimensiones y eso se relaciona
con un flujo verdad en tres dimensiones
esto induce una rotación en cada punto
del espacio y lo que va a ocurrir es que
vamos a asociar un vector en cada punto
del espacio para responder la pregunta
de cómo puede un fluído inducir una
rotación verdad y quizás me estoy
adelantando por ahora solo tenemos que
concentrarnos en un solo punto de
rotación verdad y en un único vector
correspondiente pero es importante que
tengas esto en mente para cuando nos
adentremos al tema del rotacional en
tres dimensiones bueno nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo